é boa tarde obrigada é então
principalmente pra gente quer biólogo e
não sei se é uma coisa geral mas quando
o nenezinho da gente nasce tem uma
segunda pergunta que a gente faz
claro que a primeira é saber se o bebê
está saudável
a segunda do ponto de vista biológico é
olhar pra minha bebezinha e pensar se o
dna é o mesmo em todas as células como é
que pode que esse olhar diferente do
nariz que é diferente do neurônio ou
diferente do fígado
então hoje a gente vai falar sobre
controles que existe no corpo e que dão
essa especificidade de tecidos
é a gente pode comparar como se isso
fosse é uma biblioteca é o nosso
organismo na nossa célula não deixa de
ser é e essa mesma estrutura que também
a estrutura de um computador você tem
uma biblioteca no caso da célula nós
temos em torno de 20 mil genes mas é a
gente sabe que não tem como uma pessoa
lê 20 mil livros ao mesmo tempo então de
acordo com o estímulo ou da necessidade
daquele momento você vai selecionar uma
coleção desses livros para ler
então quando a gente está próximo ao
natal a gente vai selecionar livros de
fazer receitas de natal
pelo menos eu acredito que ninguém está
fazendo um ovo de páscoa em dezembro
então é importante pensar que essa
seleção ela tem algum motivo e tem
alguma programação é é a gente não vai
fazer somente um tipo de biscoito de
natal porque ainda assim a gente tem
particularidades dentro desse universo
então quando uma condição específica da
célula é determinada é em torno de 2 mil
desses 20 mil genes que são lidos na
de momento e são interpretados então
assim que eu escolho o livro que eu vou
ler é preciso seguir alguma receita essa
receita na cela é denominada são os
conhecidos rn as mensageiras então essas
mensagens
elas têm códigos dentro delas elas nada
mais são do que nucleotídeos até o g
como nós conhecemos o código genético
mas elas têm instruções que dizem onde
começa uma parte dessa receita onde ela
termina por quanto tempo ela tem que
ficar naquele é naquela condição e até
sinais que dizem que ela precisa ser
destruída em alguns minutos ou algumas
horas então uma vez escolhidas essas
receitas elas é que vão da a
especificidade da condição
então é se a gente seguir a receita essa
mesma receita ainda assim pode originar
pequenas variações se eu tenho a receita
do dinter bebe ela é fixa mas diferentes
formatos dela ainda pode nos garantir
bonequinhos estrelinhas ou qualquer
outro formato
isso é para ilustrar que essas mensagens
celulares ou rn as mensageiras elas têm
uma variabilidade muito grande
aqueles 20 mil genes fixos que estão na
célula é podem originar em torno de
cinco vezes mais proteínas funcionais lá
na frente isso quer dizer o que é que o
dna é uma coisa um pouco mais estável
as mensagens têm diferentes combinações
que vão gerar uma gama maior de
proteínas lá no final do que o número de
genes iniciais
então no nosso grupo de pesquisa é
pergunta específica é como que uma
célula tronco que é
não tem nenhum comprometimento ela pode
ter o programinha específico ativado de
mensagens corretas em um determinado
momento de estímulo e c diferenciada no
neurônio porque essa célula não virou
uma célula do fígado
então nós sabemos as condições é fator
esquecer foram estudados ao longo de
muitos anos que precisam ser ativados ou
lidos
então dentro do ambiente de laboratório
conseguimos fazer com que essas células
tornem-se neurônios e não células
cardíacas que inclusive conseguem pulsar
nessa placa é de laboratório
esse programa é envolve em torno de duas
a três mil mensagens que podem ser
quantificados
é dentro dessas perguntas no nosso grupo
nós queremos saber por exemplo como é
que essas mensagens são levadas do corpo
do neurônio pro pelo axônio prudente
litos e para a cela vizinha que precisa
receber um estímulo então nós estamos
estudando como é que esses conjuntos de
mensagens são mantidos já muito próximos
da cela vizinha para uma rápida
mobilização e passagem do sinal pra
célula seguinte se a gente for pensar em
modelos realmente biológicos e amostras
de pacientes nós já podemos observar
durante um trabalho que eu fiz no pós
doutorado que mensagens defeituosas por
exemplo em crianças com autismo com
esquizofrenia
elas podem acabar resultando em
neurônios que tem projeções mais curtas
do que seria um neurônio normal onde
elas estariam mais longas comunicando
com a célula vizinha
então dentro desses conceitos
nós vamos também interage agora com o
consórcio que vai se estabelecer na
unicamp que é o estrutural genomics
consórcio
dentro desse consórcio o objetivo é do
dna até pequenas moléculas que tem o
potencial para tratamento
o que nós queremos fazer é é com essa
colaboração desse grupo que é canadense
e também é dada da inglaterra é utilizar
essas moléculas que serão produzidas
adicioná-las a nossas células que têm
características similares a doenças e
ver que moléculas conseguem fazer essa
célula voltar ao normal
então o que eu quero passar de mensagem
é que você estudar num laboratório
células que são similares às dos
pacientes ou até extraídas de pacientes
não são necessariamente para serem
colocadas de volta num paciente mas elas
são um modelo onde você vai poder
descobrir drogas que talvez sejam
específicas para aquele problema ou para
aquele paciente
o objetivo a longo prazo é encontrarmos
uma medicina personalizada baseada
nesses ensaios de laboratório e com isso
eu gostaria de agradecer e desejar boas
festas